Dan Ackerman is an editorial director at
CNET and joins us now with some tips on
how technology can help you reach your
goals in the New Year Dan the man what's
up I got to tell you if you have some
resolutions I got some gadgets for you
okay okay it's a natural match all right
so first up you have something that
could help people with health and
fitness related resolutions what do you
have everyone says they're going to work
out okay it's kind of how do you get
motivated how do you do it what about
working out in VR I know that sounds
crazy but the headsets now they're
Wireless they're lightweight there's a
lot of exercise programs there's boxing
programs there's music programs where
you're like your lightsabering music
notes where they come at you I've seen
people lose a ton of weight do a ton of
aerobic exercise with something like the
Oculus or the Now The Meta Quest 2. but
what is can I just be the one grinch
here and say what if you just put on
like Jane Fonda workout video is there
any different in sitting in your living
room and watching somebody doing on a TV
screen I would get the YouTube app for
this and watch the Jane Fonda videos
with the headset on
all right we would definitely do the
lightsaber one yeah I would absolutely
do that one you know me really well um
all right so next you have something for
people who want to get more organized
you got a Kindle scribe you know people
always say that when I get into
journaling or they're going to get a
notebook and do list making and organize
their lives there's a lot of paper
involved the Kindle scribe is a new
version of the Kindle it's an eating
tablet with a stylus and you can
actually make all your notes on it you
can do your journals on it I've started
my to-do list on it I find it's a great
way to do it because I find if I write
something I remember it better that if I
type it but this way I don't have to
carry around a bunch of different
notebooks and papers and stuff I can
just keep reusing this and I can also
read all my Kindle books on it does it
come in a smaller size or is that the
only size this is the new size that's
bigger because it's notebook you can get
a regular Kindle but you can't write on
those with a stylus that's what's new
about this guy that's why it's called
the Scribe and it comes with the little
stylus so what about people who are
always losing their keys or their phone
I'm asking for a friend
yeah right
the thing is to get obviously like an
Apple Air tag or a tile tracker and
that's fine we've talked about those
before but then how do you use them it's
just like a little puck well you should
get those but then get some of these
accessories you get a little wallet case
you can put the thing it's what's
actually useful because you can actually
put it somewhere I took my 3D printer
and I made a little 3D printed key ring
I can carry it around you can slip this
in your wallet these are all like you
know 10 or 20 bucks and the air tags are
like 29 so you know if you have one of
these you kind of need one of these
accessories for it but that makes it so
much more useful you have something that
combines high-tech and low Tech and has
to do with people who might have trouble
with passwords listen get your passwords
organized I always say everyone should
use a password manager whether it's one
password or or any of the other ones
that's fine but some people are never
going to do that they're going to write
them down on like Post-it notes and
stuff I used to make fun with my mother
and other people for using a password
notebook where you actually wrote the
passwords down but I've come around now
I agree that this is actually okay
because it's one physical copy you know
where it is you're not emailing your
yourself the password you're not putting
in the text file a Post-It note so you
can maintain the security of this one
little notebook and keep it in your
house locked up you know what at the end
of the day if you're not going to use a
regular password manager I'm actually
okay with this now I've come around you
just have to find the password book
password book
um write it down correctly in the
notebook that's that's what a lot of
people get tripped up so Dan there was
this recent social media Trend where
people were submitting photos to an app
I think it was called lens and it turned
their photos into a work of art I saw a
Toya your wife yeah she did it it looked
amazing you did it as well I think we
have some of your uh Dan Ackerman work
of art like we have oh wow there it is
right
wow you look like a bond villain
I look like a crypto bro in the first
one and like a Sci-Fi card yeah you say
this is here to stay you know all this
kind of stuff this generative AI whether
it's Dolly whether it's this whether
it's the chat GPT that's writing things
for people we've seen this develop so
much even in the last couple of months I
think it's going to be a huge trend for
2023 I've seen people writing School
essays with it answering questions
someone said you can never send a
take-home test home with students
anymore I I took some yeah I took some
school questions and I asked a teacher I
know about them and she said yeah this
would get like a b b plus I'm like
that's probably okay for a lot of people
yeah there you go would have been a
better student if I would have that
Dan Ackerman thank you so much Happy New
Year we'll be right back